well as you know it's been a hard time
for local businesses this entire year
and with even more restrictions
the past couple of weeks governor steve
sisilak ordered restaurants and bars to
cut capacity from
50 down to 25 percent we spoke with mary
beth seawall the head of the vegas
chamber for this week's senior business
and she explained businesses are getting
even more creative now
to comply with this latest round of
restrictions
they're really working hard to stay at
their capacities and you see the video
it's really
tough to see some of the empty bars and
restaurants that we're seeing
and they're trying really hard it's it's
devastating for some of our businesses i
have to tell you
and some of them are closing up shop but
they really are working hard to try to
comply
yeah and they've spent a lot of money to
comply already it's been a struggle for
businesses
and even more so right now the holiday
season usually makes up about
20 percent of annual sales for business
we're encouraging people especially
through this holiday shopping season
to to shop small shop local
because that really does help our small
businesses to survive and thrive
and you know when when you shop local
you are keeping people employed in our
community and it's so important to the
job market and the local economy
that we do shop small and you can watch
the rest of that interview with mary
beth we talked about a lot of different
topics it's on our website 8newsnow.com
john